but um we really pushed forward even the
most fundamental aspects of of what
makes a Call of Duty game with Modern
Warfare 2 and it's been really amazing
for me to come on board uh this past
year and see these Innovations coming to
life to hear Jeff jump into you know
breaking down the 1v1
um and personally for me uh water or
water I've seen the memes we love water
it's really hard to make in games
um but the Aquatic combat some of the
things you're able to do with vehicles
in the water I think that level of
immersion is really going to speak to
fans and has been something that I've
really enjoyed playing the last uh last
couple months aquatic combat Steph loves
to swim um Joe can we can we go into
some details about our water-based
adventures in MW2 yeah I mean last game
we really wanted to add water and we
knew we didn't have time right so in
verdance we froze the rivers and we made
the outskirts just to kill trigger in
this game as soon as we started Modern
Warfare 2 we leaned into water both
visually beautiful caustics there's
waves with white caps but we also the
gameplay side there's unique ballistics
underwater you only can use certain
weapons underwater your pistol is your
weapon underwater otherwise you can't
use your primary weapons but it's also a
nice cover or evasion mechanic if you're
getting shot at you can dive into the
water and as you get deeper it gets
murkier like the farther you are from
something you can't see it and so it's
been super fun for us to to dig into
water and really Flex on what water
could be in Call of Duty and you saw the
boats and the mine that floats and every
piece of equipment yeah I love it
filtered like how does it work through
water like we had to look at everything
in the game and say how does it work in
water what's the best version our
vehicles will just slowly submerge yeah
really wood instead of blinking out yeah
I have a lot of details behaviors are
awesome oh my god well I cannot wait to
uh can't quite wait to literally dip my
toes into those Wars but guys let's not
forget about your ground in the air like
I mean what else is going to be coming
to the movement system Joe where we go
well you know last game we did Mount um
and we had slide and even though we're a
military shooter fluid movement is super
important to us so this game as you saw
in the trailer you can see here on the
video we have a new ledgehang mechanic
and that's essentially a high mantle but
instead of doing a high mantle and
throwing yourself up over into combat
you can now Peak if you have a pistol
you can pull that pistol out and use
that
um we also added a dive you know last
game we had the slide that kept your gun
up but we really wanted players to have
an option where if they're getting shot
at they don't know where they're getting
shot at they can get down get out of
fire but the other really cool thing is
it Dives just high enough to let you get
through a window and so if you throw a
grenade up into a building Second Story
often you'll see players you know like
rats leaving a ship diving out through
the windows and uh it's just another
it's another option for players in in
combat yeah and all of these Dynamic
movements mean you can interact with
vehicles specifically in a very cool way
I'm Gonna Save uh some of that some of
that gas for when we get to war zone 2.0
but uh it's a really exciting all right
vehicle details to come uh but now guys
let's talk about equipment obviously
Call of Duty crazy sandbox a lot of cool
toys to play with uh Joe what are some
of the new Dynamite new items that we're
going to be throwing at each other and
equipping and using in all sorts in the
next game I mean you saw some cool stuff
from the trailer you saw the drill
charge you saw the shark stick um one of
the other coins you saw is the
inflatable decoy and this is a mine that
you can throw out and it basically sits
there and if player gets close to it it
auto deploys and uh basically inflates
like a car airbag going off and it faces
the person that triggered it and so it's
a great distraction technique you can
honestly fire it off with a with a
clacker if you want to control when it
goes off you can throw it in water and
here you just saw the the DDOS we added
all this equipment into this game and
the DDOS is our kind of answer of like
hey I'm going to breach this building I
want to go clean house but I don't want
to deal deal with all the [ __ ] inside so
I'm gonna hit the DDOS boom it's going
to shut down everything I can move in
yeah and clear that room
um you saw the heartbeat sensor is back
it's got a new look but it also has a
battery as a balancing mechanic so you
can't use it indefinitely in war zone
um and there's I mean there's this
attack cam too yeah which to me is
um my personal favorite you can put out
a lot of them and even you can patch
into your teammates so you can it gets a
little crazy yeah kind of like a sticky
GoPro but will actually Mark your
enemies for um your team yeah so it's
it's I expect to see a lot of fun
there's so many so many toys and new
tools that were like we just want
players to get in and play with I think
there's something like 13 field upgrades
you know between Warzone and core and P
and it's it's pretty awesome oh my God
until they open